meanwhile dr anthony fauci facing
growing calls by republicans to be fired
after new documents suggest he may have
lied about u.s support for gain of
function research when he had this back
and forth
the nih has not ever and does not now
fund
gain of function research
in the wuhan institute government
scientists like yourself who favor gain
of function i don't favor gain of
function research in china
naturally that are not correct
but new reporting from the intercept is
reigniting questions about covet origins
and the lab in china nicholas wade is a
former investigative science reporter
for the new york times he joins us right
now nicholas good morning
good morning when you look at these 900
pages that the intercept was able to uh
get through freedom of information act
it sure looks like gain of function was
going on at that lab that we helped fund
uh yes it certainly does they were
taking viruses related to
the family of viruses and they were
sticking into the spike protein genes
from other viruses and they were getting
them to infect
humanized mice as it's called and
showing that the
new viruses they had created were
more pertinent than the viruses they
came from that is the
standing definition of gain of function
right so when when fauci has been up on
capitol hill particularly sparring with
rand paul he said
we never did that but when you listen to
him it sounds like the the lawyers at
the national institutes of health have
said okay
we're going to define it as something
over here and you can
you will be legitimate in saying this dr
fauci and it just sounds like he's
hiding behind legal weasel words to get
away with something that it looks like
we did
well i think you're exactly right and
gainer function is a very hard thing to
define and there have been
varying definitions of it over time so i
think i think dr fauci has one in mind
that as you say his lawyers have told
him is is defensible but i wish he'd
come out and explain
uh what it was because right now it's
not terribly clear sure there are a
number of republicans uh nicholas who
suggests that because he lied
to congress he should go but joe biden's
administration has made made it very
clear under no circumstances would they
ever fire dr fauci you know he's he's
too big to fire apparently
well i'm just a science writer so this
is probably about my pay grade but i i
regard him as a long time sort of public
servant he has a very difficult
job he served with integrity he does he
does the best he he can i am puzzled by
his
behavior on this particular instance in
instance of the wuhan grant i wish he'd
be more forthcoming i wish you to
explain as we've discussed exactly why
it was not gain of function i wish you
would
tell us why he rejected the initial
report back in january 2020 from a group
of expert virologists that they thought
this virus was man-made
there are lots of things that he has yet
to tell us but he's gone into stone wall
mode on this instant and uh i wish he'd
just tell us more absolutely 651 000
americans have died i think we i think
we are owed an explanation by our
government if the government actually
knows what happened
i would say so i don't think the
government may not know exactly what
happened but it certainly has had lots
of information well all the information
in the
documents released yesterday by the
intercept all that would have been
extremely useful if the government had
released it in january 2020 the whole
investigation into the vast oceans might
have taken a very different term
indeed nicholas wade former new york
times investigative science reporter sir
thank you very much